he's in your steps you were all at the
repulsive age where you smell and I'd
rather not be with you but since the
other teachers at the school have yet to
give you any good advice here those with
the male anatomy might think of the
grand idea to use the engorgement charm
on yourself if you'd like to avoid a
trip to the hospital wing I'd advise
against it why is he looking at me lunch
be warned that unprotected copulation
between witches and wizards will result
in sexually transmitted jinx says they
are uncontrollable and extremely painful
I'll spare you the details but know that
you do not want to find yourself with
Sectumsempra knees Oh
open your books to page 105 can anyone
tell me what happens when you mix ash
Winder eggs Rose thorns peppermint
pardon moonstone and dust
yes Miss Granger the love potion a
molten TIA professor but it's illegal
for students to make it so correct
a single drop could cloud recipients
mine and also ones discretion for up to
24 hours wait for in the past it has
been used to seduce one seducible
something you'd like to share with the
class mr. Malfoy no professor he said it
must be our pot as mom got knocked up 10
points from Slytherin what only 10 and
Gryffindor excuse me professor 20 anyone
else care to interrupt any further I
have a question by all means do us if
it's illegal then why did you tell us
the ingredients keep your mouth shut
keep your mouth shut I have a lot more
at stake here hey Ron
isn't that what Romilda used on you yes
but wait what it doesn't count because
well actually wait does it it was an
accident
I mean he said he wanted to try it
professor
how did you not know about this that was
different
yeah it was meant for Harry how is that
different we take these matters very
seriously Hey look I just made some
super easily this is not others are
supposed to go give me that
professor this label says but when no
means yes are you going to punish him no
jeopardizes Quidditch career what hmm
anywhere you have an arsenal of spells
with which to defend yourself Miss
Granger
oh we could I don't know teach people
not to use love potions your steps open
your books to the section on love
potions but Sir there is no section on
love potions exactly can anyone tell me
what consent means
sometimes you don't get what you want
and you have to split you on tile like
protecting the offspring of your
rejection but that doesn't neither here
nor there plus is dismissed
take these prophylactics on your way out